lauren is back and you had a chance to
talk to
tyra banks and she just dropped like
fashion gold on you like how to pose
what's this kevin are you doing the tyra
i'm doing the turn right now she spilled
her secrets one of the most exciting
things about dancing with the stars this
season
is seeing what tyra wears each week and
she blessed me with her fashion rules to
live by
[Applause]
all right let's do this
do i look like i'm like a halloween
costume right now no you look stylish
tell me about how you weigh in on looks
give me a little behind the scenes
there's certain rules that i have
making sure that the waist is snatched
um
because if it's not i'm well endowed
naturally
and it can look a little bit like a moo
moo i have very broad shoulders and
sometimes the dress doesn't really cover
the shoulder
so it's got to be wide enough up here we
can't have satin
on the boobies on the tummy or on the
booty
satin on my booty show cellulite so
there's all these like a checklist
tyra's mandate when she took over as the
host of dancing
up the fashion game so far she's had at
least
two quick changes in every show and
she's planning up to
six different looks for the finale on
november 23rd have you ever had an oh my
gosh we might not make it back on the
live tv
moment yeah i think it was like the
third fourth episode i walk out and my
hand is on my back
and i i was holding my dress together it
was not zipped up and i didn't have on
any of my jewelry
so then you'll notice a couple of acts
later my hand is down i'm zipped up and
i have on jewelry
most of the smize queens pieces are
custom made for her five foot ten
physique
like the yellow tool gown she wore on
monday i have to
walk over to it and then step
into this hole crazy
so i'm like oh that's why i fit so good
because
sometimes i put something on and i'm
like okay they obviously
don't know i got a booty because it's
something like off the runway
yes i used to model did fashion shows
fashion weeks all across the globe
but i don't have that body anymore but
for some reason designers
just think oh she was a model and let's
give her this size four honey can you
add a 10 to that
in women we deal with that our bodies
being different at different times in
our life
i just have gone up and down and weight
my entire career yeah
my entire career i'm like you just never
know what timer you're gonna get
and now i i think i've probably gone a
little bit way on the other side
and then but what happens is when you
have a really good stylist
they like know how to do all the tips
and tricks as do i
so then you're like do i really need to
lose weight my waist is snatched right
now i think i'm fine